foreign
thanks for having me today my name is
Abhijit Lilly I'm a Solutions engineer
at hortonworks how many of you know who
hortonworks is in this room
all right cool 50 all right so I'll just
spend a couple of minutes
explaining who Autumn works is right so
we all know what Hadoop is so it's
around 2004 2005 time frame Yahoo
decided to build this file system an
analytics framework based on Google's
paper for mapreduce and hdfs so they
formed a team of 30 or so Engineers to
build that system and around 2006 uh you
know this open source a project called
Apache Hadoop which had hdfs and
mapreduce as initial projects and they
started working with Facebook and
building a extensive data warehouse
platform now fast forward to 2011 Yahoo
decided to make this team as a separate
company and that's how hortonworks was
born so we took original 30 Engineers
which built Apache Hadoop from Yahoo and
created a company called hortonworks
the goal was to create an Enterprise
radio Hadoop we know there's lots of
gaps in Hadoop and we wanted to make
sure that we fill up all these gaps and
make Apache Hadoop Enterprise ready
right and one of the projects or two of
the projects we're going to talk about
is Stinger right or stinger and Tay
specifically so I'm going to follow the
same theme that Elliott had is to make
the interactive queries better right and
we all know Hive has certain gaps today
it is great for querying large amounts
of data but it's not that fast for
interactive querying or doing
dashboarding type of work so around six
months ago we started working with
Facebook to invest more heavily on high
because a primarily all of the customers
who are using Hadoop today are using
Hive as their data warehouse or
extension to that data warehouse I'm
certainly not saying we're replacing
your data warehouse but extension to
that data warehouse right and lots of
investment lots of code has been
developed around Hive and the way Hive
ql was built was kind of difficult
originally initially when they started
contributing to it so people have
learned their ways from traditional SQL
into Hive kill right so now all these
skill sets are basically formed around
Hive itself so we wanted to take Hive
into the Next Generation High which
supports interactive querying
dashboarding visualization so that you
don't have to run a query go get a cup
of coffee and your results will be there
right so they we need to interact with
the system at a large scale so we
essentially make Stinger as an
initiative Stinger is not a product
Stinger is built on an initiative which
basically means we're going to make Hive
better by improving multiple projects
right so if you see Hive today
underneath the high framework is
mapreduce so essentially when you write
any queries in hive it turns into a
mapreduce job underneath right so that's
one
is there any question
the second one is we know Hive curl is
not completely SQL compliant right so we
want to make sure that we give deep
analytical functionality right we want
to make sure we have a wide variety of
windowing functions and we'll see where
we are at with that right so those are
the two
um two-pronged approach we're trading
right so first improve the latency
improve the throughput of Hive itself
and then improve the functionality of
SQL because we all know SQL as we as we
learn right so three things that come
with this one is take this map reduce
engine and basically improve it
something else okay because we know
mapreduce framework is not
fast enough for interactive querying
secondly do and as Google release uh the
paper on a on the on the Dremel we
realize that columnar format gives us
better functionality so we're investing
heavily on the orc file format and a
couple of them couple of the features
and functions are already released into
Hive 11. we'll talk about that and last
but not least
is the framework will eventually replace
mapreduce underneath high right for
better functionality and improve speed
okay
so
um as I said it's it's an initiative
right it's not it's not a product it's
not a singular product uh so we what we
did is we essentially divide divided up
into three phases so for the first phase
we did two things one is uh essentially
did the base optimizations and uh we
released orc files and that has been
released with Apache Hadoop uh in an
open source world and it's Hive 11 as
the project right so you can download
high of 11 today from Apache or from
hortonwers.com and you will get the base
optimizations in memory has joined as
well as the orc file format the second
one is it's kind of ironic right so the
new PMC or the new chair of Apache is
Microsoft technical architect isn't that
funny but that's that's great because
they're contributing very heavily so one
of the core Focus he brought his name is
Chris Douglas he brought was we need to
make this better he wrote half of the
sequel ANSI standard so one of the focus
he got into Hive is let's make these SQL
query language or make Hive kill as good
as SQL query language so a lot of
improvements has gone into the SQL you
know compatible types and windowing
functions as a part of Hive 11. and
we're adding more and more uh features
to it as we go along into this journey
the second phase of this project is
essentially The Hive query server which
is backed by Tays tez in Hindi or in
Indian language means fast nothing else
right so what we're doing is essentially
replacing the mapreduce framework and
picking it out and putting uh tez
underneath it so it
the the downside to how the map reduces
essentially it has startup costs for
your jvms as well as the cleanup costs
so there's always a uh an expense of
your query to start and then wait for
the execution and then basically clean
up so that will go away because it'll be
a pre-warm containers and they'll give
you an ability to do lower latency
queries you submit a job it's ready to
go and it'll function
obviously query planner improvements are
ongoing so a couple of things that you
know we'll see in the next few slides as
how mapreduce work right and how query
planner is trying to uh you know improve
the data structure improve the uh
mapreduce jobs underneath today and then
how it will function with Des
a vector query engine it will be with
buffer caching it will be available end
of the year time frame uh give or take
so that will improve the whole Apache
Hive itself uh as close as to
interactive query engine now that does
not mean this is a replacement for MPP
right so the the far far end goal for
this is adding what MPP does today or
traditional stores like add business
rules right today we don't have business
rule more security structure around that
right so that's that's going to come way
later after these phases so that's
that's one of the things that we're also
working on putting into roadmap and
essentially if you look at Apache jiro's
or if you follow those you will see that
a lot of work is going on a lot of
people are thinking about what they can
what they can take from the traditional
edw system and make Hive better right so
we're essentially doubling down on hive
because a uh
the file formats or the data sits into
Hive or sits onto sdfs represented by
Hive can be accessed by other tools into
Hadoop so it makes ecosystem better it
makes the access of data from other
systems better rather than creating a
net new format right and there there's
other projects going on that will help
it improve further
um you
I'll just keep it down
so where we are at today so as of last
month Hive 11 was released right high of
11 includes one key feature is
analytical function so it's not Inc it's
actually rank sorry I it's it's a typo
in there so I I just developed a new
function in SQL right Ang so no it's
it's rank uh we had lead lag first value
last value and aggregate over functions
are now available as a part of Hive 11
right there are certain improvements
such as broadcast join and SMB joins
that are available as well as a lot of a
lot of new features for partitioning
right so if you do partitioning today
with virtual columns you will see
significant improvement with Hive 11
right with Hive 10 if you do virtual
column partitioning it puts lots of
pressure on name node here we we made it
a lot a lot more better in hive 11.
we'll talk about orc file a little bit
later in the slides but as as Elliot
said it's based on Google Dremel
projects so it's a columnar format and
it includes a lot more features I have a
Nick slider too
test Alpha was released also so we
released has as an alpha because Tes
requires Hadoop tool which is still in
Alpha 2. Hadoop tuo has a new resource
scheduling function called yarn and Tes
will run as a container within the yarn
application as the application of yarn
so tez released as an alpha about a
month ago so you can go ahead go to
Apache or go to hortonworks.com and
download uh you'll have to compile it
but you can play with test today
so what's the goal right so today we
know we can do this we can do data
mining we can do uh batch reporting but
this part the dashboard virtual
visualization and uh parameterized
reporting it's really tricky you can do
it but it takes a lot of time and
patience users don't have patience to
change one field and see how the
visualization changes right it still
takes you know a few seconds to just
start the query and just get the data
out so the the goal is to make that
interactive right an idea is to have uh
you know make it more SQL friendly right
have all the SQL functions
um in the meantime we have also built in
an open source odbc driver so you can
download it and it has its own SQL
engine small part of SQL engine built
into it so if you have any visualization
Tools in front of Hive the conversion of
SQL to hiveql is much better it has
improved from from a visualization uh
tools perspective not 100 but it's still
there right so the queer the the SQL
engine the driver itself has a lot more
features than before so you can go ahead
download that for free as well
okay so what we did in Hive 11 right so
first the intelligent Optimizer so
in-memory has joins are now available uh
we are also able to make certain
improvements and as I said in Virtual
column partitioning so we can now
ideally scan through a big file and we
look at directory structure if it's
available we can go in and pull the data
fast enough star schema joins and this
was one of the key things because we're
able to do load the dimension tables
into memory and then distribute via
distributed cache so it's speed up
things off the SQL query now how fast is
again depends on your query but at least
it's much much faster than where Hive 10
was two months ago
um
lower footprint or fact tables that's
one of the things that I would like to
mention because it was quite an
improvement from from the memory
utilization perspective task trackers
let's see all right so hints are very
key because what happened was with Hive
10 hints it's really not optimal so it
created lots of mapreduce pipelines now
those requirements of hints are kind of
gone away so high of 11 is much better
and you don't have to there's no need
for hints it optimizes better because
they're a lot more jiras that went into
Hive 11 that improves the functions that
are the need of hands gone away now
yeah
okay so this is one of the things that
we did and this is no way means the
speed of the query but if you look at it
the number of steps that mapreduce has
to take that's basically increment
incrementally added changes to it so if
you look at the hive 10 without hands
you can see there are lots of multiple
mapreduce job gets uh you know multiple
mapreduce stages started here with Hive
11 star schema join without hints we
could do that only into a uh you know a
two-step process of mapreduce so some of
the things if you look at those jiras we
remove the need of a hint to the
optimizer itself so you'll see with Hive
11 your queries will now run faster
because the number of mapreduce job will
essentially the need of the number of
approach will be reduced one key feature
for this are actually one key benefit of
this is will come with tests because
today what happens is we you write a map
for use job the intermediate output of
the task lands on the disk right and we
all know the disk is much much slower
than memory so the goal or the the
Improvement what in test is essentially
take that intermediate output of the
task and keep it in memory
now we're able to do instead of reading
that data from disk again we can read
the data faster in memory itself so
that's the one of the step to go to test
when you go to Hadoop to go and use Tes
along with Hive and Hadoop 2o you'll be
able to see the squares improve faster
today with high of 11 we will still
collapse that output task onto the disk
for now
can you go forward
all right so we talked about orc file
right
we looked at the storage or the data
structure how how the data gets laid out
so you have text file your RC file your
sequence file and another new format or
C file this is a columnar structure
we're able to get into Hive 11 or moving
forward into high because it is much
faster right it makes better and it's
evolved in Google Dremel format so
Google would release that paper uh
foreign
about an a year ago so you know a high
oh sorry uh Facebook started working on
it along with Oracle works and we were
able to now uh produce a orc file format
right so it's a columnar format it has a
lot more features one key feature is
we're able to now consolidate the output
of the math task into a single output
file so traditionally with hives 10
without orc file you'll see output files
or output of the task will be split into
multiple files now we can put that into
a single file we can apply a block level
compression based upon data types now I
don't top of my head which I don't know
what data types but you'll be able to
apply Block Level compressions so the
footprint is smaller as well as the
amount of data needs to be written as
well as read from the disk is smaller
now we also can add Bloom filters so a
bloom filter is a data structure which
gives you
um you know a predictive
relative filtering should say gives you
an ability that this element is exist in
the data or not right so now you can add
Bloom filters in with orc file so that
you can enable quick check that's my
data there or not
okay so here's the file layout right so
one of the things that this is a simple
stripe right so if you look at a stripe
it's around 250 megabyte so it's quite
large so you can pack lots of metadata
into our C file as well as the actual
row data right and it has index data
index data also contains the Min value
max value of the rows and it also
contains the row locations where they
are and you have the stripe footer which
essentially contains the directory
location on hdfs so you can quickly go
get the location of the file it it also
has as I said Block Level compression so
you can have again it depends on the
data type which you're using today but
eventually it will be available for all
data types so 250 megabytes we think in
a stripe is large enough and it's fast
enough to accommodate that right
any questions so far on RC file
okay
so let's talk about the second phase of
the project right so what is test so tez
is a replacement I shouldn't say
replacement there will be mapreduce
framework in Hadoop 2o right it'll be
one portion of it but Taz will be a
service that will enable Hive to
essentially have a pre-warm containers
so when you launch a mapreduce task
it'll be no more launching them oh sorry
when you launch a hive query there will
not be any mapreduce charts it will run
into as a test service in the back end
so here are the goals right so we want
to enable a low-level data processing
using this engine why because we already
know that with Hive 11 when there is a
large data set High 11 you know can
function better right obviously test
will make it much much better but if you
have a large data set we're talking
terabytes multiple terabytes the
processing is still there but for
smaller data set when you look at
smaller data set we want to have
something better and going Beyond
mapreduce so that's what has that's
essentially what led to Tes investment
we want to enable efficient pipelining
of the job so the query optimizations as
well as the intermediate output of the
jobs will be the ones that will make
this much faster so we will with has
initiative we will not write the output
of intermediate map task onto the disk
so instead of doing mapreduce then doing
mapreduce you can just do mapreduce
reviews right
and obviously it is built on your arm so
it'll be a uh it's a it'll be a yarn
application
it is scheduled to go ga around
September October time frame but you can
still download this today and be able to
test it right we want to make it
um
so one thing is uh one thing with tests
that we want to make sure the hive and
pig job are no longer the step children
right so today with high one if you have
a hive and pig job they move to the end
of the queue so tomorrow if you're using
some sort of let's say capacity
scheduler it'll be treated as the
performance oriented job when you use a
test service
okay so this is essentially the
pictorial description of what it looks
like right so Tes will have a
application Master service which will
which will monitor the containers uh
which are which will be the test
containers essentially it's live jvm
it's always on jvm type of uh instance
running on all the nodes so the node
manager or there will be an application
Master for test service which will
Monitor and manage these containers
where your job will get submitted and
the data will get collected from it
okay can you go to the next slide please
so
if you look at today so you have this i
o synchronization barrier what we call
and this is what we talked about where
the data lands on the disk right so when
you have a simple query like select
something and count and group by a state
what's happening is there are multiple
map tasks are going on and the output of
those files are landing onto the disk
and then the next stage of the process
picking up that data or intermediate
data and pushing that into uh this this
map reduce next mapper use task so if
you look at the test framework we're
able to a make the query better or make
query Optimizer better obviously the
foundation of it and we already have
that and the second thing is make the i
o pipelining better because a lot of
people are using mixed set of
infrastructure within their Hadoop in
you know environment so that the i o
pipeline becomes more and more critical
for smaller data sets for larger data
sets it may or may not matter but small
our data set this is a key where if you
look at Hive and pig with tez we can
keep the intermediate data in memory and
access it from there
can you go back yes
which instances these containers
they will always be running they'll run
as a some sort of demon yes
now it'll consume some sort of memory
right but obviously then the if you look
at today's Hardware we can we can
utilize the memory better right when it
was developed if you look at Hadoop
wanna it was developed for like eight
cores for 24 to 48 gig memory machines
so that's why you will see now all these
functions are added you know set mapred
split task equal to now increase the
Heap size when you run now those needs
are gone because now people are buying
128 gig machines at the same cost they
used to buy 24 gig machines so that is
very very minor yes it will consume some
but not to the extent
okay
okay so some of the primary results and
you'll be able to test this when you
download tests right so one of the
things we did is with Hive so this is
Hive 11 queries right so that basically
improves the pipelining
um this is the reason this basically
says it's less because it's improved
data pipeline nothing else so the
optimizer has now better Improvement so
that I rather than launching hundreds of
mapreduce tasks I can pipeline it better
I can do with intent mapreduce tasks
right
yes with tests essentially the major
difference is the launch of launch of a
service or you know submitting your job
to that pretty warm container now the
reason behind that the launch if we only
say launch here but obviously when you
launch jvm there's always a shutdown
cost to it and as a part of mapreduce
job you'll see at the end but that 30
seconds time
is now gone or will be gone with Tes
when you implement a hive with tez
um
to create plan so the query planner is
you know essentially now all these
result sets are high of 11 because now
it's available as ga uh in Apache so all
these baselines we did are essentially
based on hive 11. compared to Hive 10
it's a significant Improvement because
the query planner in there
Okay so
this is the
this is essentially you know describes
as if you look at the mapreduce task you
look at that engine as a as a service
right so you submit a job to that
service you get an output it's always on
so that's why you get a low latency
right and that's that's basically what
Tes is going to be Tes is going to be a
separate instance of projects or
separate instance of application running
on yarn so you'll have you know node
manager managing in the subsequent
services along with it
can you go to the next slide please
okay so for this we talk
most of this right so this is
essentially one of the things we're
working on is potentially uh take it to
Future memory based performance
optimizations and it's not like an
in-memory database but it'll with the
extent of having more and more memory on
these servers and available will be able
to utilize these resources better right
now we have an ability to test to do
that uh previously with mapreduce we
didn't with Tes will be able to pre-warm
this container maybe you know do some
sort of caching mechanism with tests
that will improve that further so we're
still talking you know sub milliseconds
response time we're not talking
microseconds respond time but that
essentially is where we're heading with
the future all these other things are
almost in code complete state for Hive
tests and basically the whole Stinger
umbrella framework right so we're
testing now the beta phase of it and
will be released very soon and you'll be
able to download that I mean obviously
you can go to a patching compile that
but it will it is scheduled to release
for GA around September time frame
we have any more I have any more slides
right how long do I have for a great on
time
okay
sure
and actually I have your first question
I don't know if Jeremy Brown is here
the first question is
you can have one
I have two so you can have one
okay yeah
thank you
but he's right here yeah right here
14 yeah
you mentioned that they were
here and like
and like eventually going to turn into
like a transactional
s or is this
um that's about my pay grade but I'll
answer this differently right so uh the
question here is essentially with the
deeper integration with Microsoft and
hortonworks where are we taking uh tez
and high right will it be replacement
for traditional
rdbms is that a fair question
right it is
column store indexes
that that's a great question right so
that it is actually on the road map so
column store sorry I mean the question
is uh you know for example getting
column store indexing in Hive or making
it almost like an edw is that the fair
goal right so the answer is potentially
yes right I mean we are trying to get
there uh as of today the answer is no
we're not there so the first step of the
process is make sure it's equivalent to
compliant and Microsoft is contributing
very heavily to that uh through our
Microsoft partnership uh essentially two
things happen one Microsoft star
Microsoft stopped actually developing
their HPC platform altogether so there
is no shipping Microsoft HPC servers
anymore they actually pre-package
hortonore's data platform or Apache
Hadoop underneath as HD Insight so
they're thinking three ways right one we
have this bi lever analytical framework
we own it we have SharePoint we have
power pivot we have Excel 90 of the user
use that right so let's take advantage
of that second they're working on a
project called hackathon right it's one
of the things that they introduce as a
part of uh SQL Server 14 a portion of
in-memory database right so if you look
at your data access layer they're
working on microseconds response time
milliseconds response time from a SQL
database and Hadoop essentially for them
stance today is a larger repository
extension of SQL Server right now
given the framework they're building on
top of it makes the queries transparent
right because working with Hadoop for a
regular user through an Excel is
difficult today right from security from
access from connections perspective so
they're making it fully integrated
solution first piece of that is making
SQL anti-compliant second piece of that
build more framework make it more
interactive third is as I said we're
missing a lot of things that ew has
primarily we don't have business rules
right so if you look at that it's it's
it's far down the road man but
eventually it'll get there in my opinion
right
and it's not certainly not only we are
contributing it's it's a democratic
investment right so Facebook is there
Microsoft is there so it's obviously
this
foreign
yes sir
reduce
phase of one job with the map phase of
the next step in the process or house
what's happening here so Taz so if you
look at mapreduce right
oh I'm sorry so his question is what is
tez he he's trying to understand in
detail what tez is correct
okay so today if you look at mapreduce
right so mapreduce has a resource
scheduler built into it right so job
tracker manages it and it basically
distribute to all these task trackers so
what Taz is essentially it's always live
jvm engine let's think of this way you
have a Java framework or Java engine
running on every node right the query
Optimizer will submit a job to that
particular instance say go do this for
me because of your data locality and
then basically return these query
results to a centralized reducer type
framework right so in terms of map and
reduce that map and reduce becomes a
test job essentially so you're
completely replacing the mapreduce
framework and Tes is essentially
submitting the splits of those queries
across all these data nodes
so the query planner doesn't change it's
just the service which does that data
access point for you at the data
locality it changes from mapreduce to
Tes is that an answer question a little
bit
yes in a nutshell
kind of a confident added together
it takes to test
things
so it's a big submission
right so if you so okay so the question
is why is why it takes so much time so
so today when you submit a query the
query planner basically goes to job
tracker and the job tracker distribute
the work to all these task trackers
right and particular instance of that
job instantiate a jvm to do that job for
you right so there's a scheduling
framework that's built in causing that
delayed because the jvm has to start
it's roughly 30 seconds time now what if
we can eliminate that because we already
know the data locality where the data
exists and we can we can say hey if the
engine or jvm is already running we can
submit this job directly so we built
that query planner to understand what
Tes is our test framework is and
eliminated mapreduce altogether that
means no more job tracker no more
scheduling through other resource
manager yarn says okay there's another
instance of this engine is running you
have all these resources go execute it
yes
are based on maximizing resources such
as families
and Story community cells in a new
memory jobs
to our concurrency
queries happening at the same time
starting together or
um that's a great question right so we
tested some of those concurrency
patterns so if you look
sorry I disagree so he's saying all
these optimizations are basically built
on effective resource utilizations right
so what if you have multiple concurrent
queries what happens to the performance
right so
um this is not not by any means your
demon is running it has access to
everything right so it's a car it's a
kind of see grooves built onto it so if
you look at at a higher level framework
you have to use some sort of capacity
scheduler so when you pull all these
resources together and you say you Mr
customer a has a 20
execution or 20 slice of the pie you're
not going to get many more tasks on top
of it so there's always a rest resource
scheduling is going to happen from a
higher level through a capacity schedule
type of framework but you only get a
percentage of that particular instance
of resources happening on there so
effectively there will be concurrency
limits on on test service I don't know
the actual numbers for that yet to be
frank with you
at the moment yes so we haven't built
into any quotas today so that's still
available so the intermediate results
will be available as part of https yes
but there is a there's one more jira
open so that you can build into an hdfs
code AS available so that one
crazy developer cannot hold on to
everything so you can actually set
coders moving forward uh in sdfs so
there's a Jiro that'll eventually submit
that includes the total capacity
intermediate task capacity and whole
nine yards not there yet but it'll be
there but does that answer your question
yes
Plus
it is moving towards and
people yeah
because
so
sorry
okay he's basically asking that this is
basic this is essentially turning into
an MPP uh type of
a system and how will we manage
um how we manage the resource scheduling
when you have large scale of Rights just
example one and the second second I
forgot sorry
more concurrency
right so MPP okay so if you look at
resource scheduler perspective right so
yarn will combine capacity scheduler
into it right so today we have a
capacity scheduler built on top of it so
you will always get a percentage of the
resources available to you right and
that that boils down to disk memory CPU
and it's not a mapping map and reduce
task anymore or slots anymore a little
portion of the instance you can use uh
it will be combined together from a yarn
perspective so you will have effectively
out of the box anybody can kind of
default group as 100 utilization
capacity so if you start 2000 map or
2000 tasks you'll be able to do whatever
you want to do with it but essentially
the resource scheduler will be a
modified capacity scheduler built on
yarn that will effectively manage that
quarter framework I shouldn't say quote
the the resource is better for you
yes sir
so the question is what's a relationship
with new ha new High version and does it
use test so hi you mean Hive 11 yeah
right so high of 11 does not use test
High 11 still uses mapreduce it's still
based on uh map Hadoop 100 framework
the next version of however on September
time frame will use tests
absolutely yes
right so I'll repeat the question no I
remember Ruby so when is when is it
available so in a nutshell so today you
have Hive 11 available as full GA so you
can go ahead download Hive 11. that does
not come with tabs okay you can go to
hortonworks or Apache website you can
download tests as Alpha as well as the
new version of Hive with certain of
jiras made to it we can use tests so it
is available on Alpha you have to
compile it and you know use it from that
perspective
yes so in alpha alpha well Hive 11 news
so Hive 11 as a ga product no but Hive
11 combined with some other regiras and
tez as an alpha you can get the
real-time querying
good
stuff yeah that's another challenge so
what we're doing so that's that's one
thing right so you go to Apache it's
like okay I need to download this
particular project and 10 different
patches with it to get to that 11 and a
half point so what we're doing as
hortonworks we're basically combining
these and doing a quarterly release
cycle so we're essentially combining
what we what we have tested with from a
particular project and patches
perspective and putting that into a
Hardware's data platform again it's it's
open source product you can go ahead and
download from us or either from Apache
but we're making sure that Hive 11 with
the four GEOS I listed three seven eight
four for Star schema join is part of it
tested and works better
but we're actually releasing as a
quarterly release cycle right so
hortonors data platform 1.3 1.4 which
will coincide with 11 11 and a half I
shouldn't say 11 and a half whatever
please they pick up next time
any other questions
yes sir
so yes there will be right
so the question is will there be support
for TP joints right so the answer is yes
I don't know if it made to Hive 11 or
not so
and it is it is it is on the roadmap
actually
yes
any other questions
all right thank you thank you
okay